explain to me is there is there like i  i'm assuming you don't have any issues  with young boy it feels like he's just  got issues with everyone no i ain't got  issues with nobody you know  i mean type type lifestyle i live it's  there's no room for that i'm saying i'm  focused on too much to be be able to  empower what i got going to be able to  empower my family to be able to empower  myself like this this this little kid  stuff you know that's fifth grade stuff  to me now i'm saying we on bigger better  things i'm trying to change the world i  got no problem with nobody the beef  comes from the mind the beef and the  enemy is the mind whatever i move and  pride you know what i'm saying that's  what it is so